foreign
[Applause]
a new heavyweight Contender for the
largest animal to have ever lived
on display in Lima is a partial skeleton
of perisultus Colossus or the Colossal
whale from Peru
at 20 meters long and weighing 340 tons
it may out muscle the current title
holder of the largest known animal
it's an exceptional discovery
heavier than a blue whale the largest
animal that has existed and that
currently exists on our planet this
animal lived 39 million years ago in the
Peruvian sea
the massive fossils were discovered by
paleontologist Mario urbina more than a
decade ago
an international team has spent years
digging the remains from the side of a
steep Rocky slope in the Ika desert the
region was once underwater and is known
for its Marine fossil discoveries
the truth is that it has been one of the
strangest discoveries of my career I got
out of the window of a moving car
fighting with the driver who did not
want to take me to the site because it
was very far in the desert and while now
here are the results
foreign
excavated so far 13 vertebrae four ribs
and a hip bone but the skull or teeth
haven't been found
it lives at the bottom of the sea in a
coastal zone and it fed with food found
in that depth it was a hefty animal
timeline in way
in vacating they evolved to massive
sizes much earlier than previously
thought
and this museum display not only
presents the contender for the heaviest
animal yet it's also rewriting the
history of aquatic animals